all right ian
ian where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um i am from
chicago uh illinois specifically more
towards like the northwest side of
chicago so like
wicker park humboldt park um area
what was your family like growing up
my dad wasn't really in the picture like
that actively my mom was a single mom
for most of her life but she's also gay
so i i grew up with a little bit of
adversity in my family it's like
kind of allowed me to understand
a little bit differently i feel like you
know just
seeing things and just the way you
process things through that and then i
have a
sister who's
on 25
with borderline personality disorder so
i grew up with her
for a little while and then we separated
for for just a little bit um in our
teenage years
yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
i would say
it's a lot of
scattered moments that i'm still trying
to piece together
you know um
i spent a lot of time
moving
you know to different parts of the city
um predominantly grew up in a lot of
like lower income neighborhoods and i
was always just like a sore thumb
because like i'm a white kid
um in the middle of the hood you know
but i i think it's uh
i always look at it as a positive you
know
i will never
compromise my personality just for where
i'm at you know it's just i'm always be
this person
um
but yeah
you finished high school i did finish
high school barely though i didn't want
to but i did it just to appease
you know my my grandparents and my mom
really um
i just i didn't feel like
math and science are like my favorite
thing i loved art i loved like
art classics music classes anything
creative
but i very much shied away from like
mathematics i would have you know that
girl do my homework for five bucks you
know it's just
what'd you do when you graduated um
after i graduated um
i started doing
actually after i graduated i kind of
i got kicked out of the house when i was
15
um by my mom
for like i was like true in from school
i would wouldn't come home to like four
o'clock in the morning i was just like
generally a bad kid
because i was like looking for a father
figure
i was dealing with past traumas of like
sexual assault and
physical abuse
so when i got out of high school
it was almost like i'm free like i can
go do whatever the hell i want
wherever i want
so i kind of like
got into this spiral of like using drugs
after high school a little bit heavier
than i had been using them during high
school
but i also
started pursuing my creative career
and
i had done some like art shows and done
some like live performances with my
music
um which was
really a blessing
you know it's like really cool to be
able to make things that people love or
you know want to listen to every day and
then like you'll be hanging out with
somebody and they're singing your song
to you it's like really wild
um
how'd you end up in l.a
so
my best friend this past year passed
away from fentanyl
he had schizophrenia
and he was staying at my house for a
little while
and then
he ended up moving to indiana for a
little bit
and we kind of like we would still
communicate but it was just like harder
to communicate
but he would use cocaine to deal with
the voices that he was hearing and he
would tell me and our friends that it
would like
make the voices go away and it would
make him feel like he could go out in
public and be around us
um but it was just a psychosis that he
was in he just really was looking for
help
and um
he
overdosed on laced coke someone laced
his cocaine with fentanyl
and i had actually just started using
fennel at the time
and so it was like really like a
shock to me
but one of the last conversations me and
him had over tex when the last times i
spoke to him before he passed away
we had talked about coming out here and
like living out here and starting to do
music and art out here because we just
weren't happy in chicago anymore like
we we oftentimes focus a lot on like
syria
and like what's going on overseas and
that is important and very important
thing
but we have
10 11 year old kids in america holding
semiautomatic assault rifles too but we
don't talk about that
because it's not making us money you
know um yeah gangs in chicago are a
whole nother breed oh gangs or a whole
another breed um
it literally that's the thing it's like
out here in la you got
ms
you got crips you got bloods you might
have a few other like stragglers from
different gangs maybe some aryan
brothers maybe whatever you know just
penitentiary and and street gangs you
know
the way it works in chicago
is
if you took la and you just went
and squished it right together it's the
streets are not like one block out here
is probably like two three city blocks
where i'm from so like everything's just
mushed together and smushed together
and half the year you spend inside
isolated from other people because it's
just too cold to go out so you just
people build up these frustrations and
these angers and these evils
um
and
it's almost like this city doesn't want
us to learn the city doesn't want us to
grow they don't want us to shy away from
guns and drugs they want us to consume
it you know um
one of the biggest things i noticed
growing up from like when i was like in
high school when i was old enough to
understand politics a little bit
there was a lot of school closings
in chicago and they were shutting down
schools
and it's like well if i can't teach kids
right from wrong what are they going to
go out and do do the wrong things you
know gangs fall into that setting as
well like they it's it's sad it's [ __ ]
up but they usually attack in your home
life or they're going to attack in your
school life or they're going to attack
your street life but somewhere they're
going to try to grab on to you and say
this is a better family like now i'm not
i'm not a gang member nor am i really
affiliated with any type of
gangs but i've have friends who are who
have died from
gun violence in chicago one of my
friends adam passed away
um
like about almost a year ago now
uh got shot nine times in front of his
house
um
and it literally a week before i saw him
i told him he was just you every time
he'd eat someone would knock on the door
yo he would load his pistol [ __ ] it and
it's just like yo chill like we're safe
you're around your friends like you
don't have to worry but you just saw
this like
fear in his eyes that just was like
almost keeping him alive in a weird way
because he was just so scared like
you know i i
chicago is is a
they don't have resources like they have
here in l.a
like they don't have
mental health resources like they got
out here they don't pass out narcan you
can't have a tent on the side of the
street like a lot of the things that
happen
is not the same for chicago you know
i've personally in my own experience
you know racism in police and i think
police are also a systematic
uh gang it's just a gang that's a little
bit more appreciated by society like a
mafia you know
um but i've seen cops
you know racially profile my friends
um and then i'm sitting there
the only person who actually did
something wrong and they won't arrest me
but they're taking my friends in
it's just like weird stuff like you know
like
i feel like because i'm a white man
you know um in america
i
am at liberty to speak on what i see and
what i notice and not lie about it you
know
i uh i could deny that there's racism in
america i could deny that there's
violence in chicago i could deny that
school is important but i'd be lying you
know and that's a big part of actually
one of the reasons why i wanted to come
in here and do this in the first place
is just being like honest it's like this
is my place to be honest and tell my
story so people know that they're not
alone like
you know
i uh
this past year went to
rehab we got sober for around like seven
months and while i was in rehab i got
diagnosed with complex ptsd
my entire life i was trying to figure
out what was wrong with me why i was the
way i am i was like there's a dd it's
bipolar it's
you know you have a mood disorder like
it was all these things and it wasn't
until they told me complex ptsd cp at
ptsd that it finally like clicked to me
and i was like
actually that makes a lot of sense
you know
um just due to like
the early life like so some of the
youngest memories i have
are
somebody assaulting me you know sexually
um
some of the earliest memories i have are
of like just violent nature in my home
and around my house and it's like no one
wants that no one plans for that but
it's just the way the world is you know
when you have kids raising kids you know
my mom had my sister when she was 20 had
me when she was 23. that's a child
raising a child you know there's no
right way to do this she just tried the
best she could
but from that we also have to build our
own experiences and our own knowledge
and we have to [ __ ] up
to we have to mess up to like
learn you know and to to better
ourselves um it's almost like trial and
error so that's why when you ask me what
i did after heist you know after my high
school career i was like i kind of just
went back wild to see how far i could go
with it and then i was like i reeled it
in slowly when i realized it was kind of
not healthy for me but how old do you
know i'm 22 i'm still young you know
i get told that on a regular basis
you're so young you could do so much
and like i guess i can do so much you
know i got to just
find my niche and just find the people
that you know
i can
speak to and just help them like that's
the biggest thing is it's like
where i'm from there isn't a lot of
support systems so like a big thing in
my life is now developing support
systems and trustworthy groups of people
that i can put myself around so i never
have to deal with the past again so i'm
not repeating this cycle
because you know
i've been stabbed you know i i put
myself in bad situations and karma came
back to me and put me in you know like
really crazy uncomfortable situations
but
you know part of that is the growth and
development of becoming an adult you
know and that's like
things you have to go through i
definitely notice there's a difference
between the way that my mom treats my
sister and the way that she treats me in
in no way loving though it's the love is
the same
but when it comes to like taking care of
my sister my mom's always been willing
to take that extra mile and it's almost
like as a man in society i've kind of
had to take that step myself i kind of
had to be my own parent cook for myself
you know pay my own bills you know um
but i'm glad i did you know i wouldn't
have life any other way it's it's as
[ __ ] up as i am as screwy and [ __ ]
up as i am i wouldn't have it any other
way
because
a lot of people right now are getting to
the age of 22 and dying before they ever
get a chance to really change the world
the way they want it
i'm still here so if i can make that
change
you know i mean like why not do it you
know that's that's why i'm a creative
that's why i do art that's why i do all
this stuff because i can't talk about
how i i well i can talk about it but i
don't know the proper way to
express
what it felt like to be assaulted as an
adult or a child you know what i mean
like
um
it's just one of those things where like
when you get into a creative space you
can say all of that without ever saying
anything you know and people can feel it
um
and i've also learned that
your family
you don't have to like
my mom obviously is not supportive of
the face tattoos the arm tattoos and
everything like that but something in my
spirit and in my heart told me this is
who i was gonna be forever like
so when i did it it was a commitment
that i was making to a craft a
commitment i was making to a lifestyle
that i wanted to be happy in my skin and
with this identity and as i started
doing that i realized more about
beauty comes from within and you know i
wasn't trying to deal with what came
inside i was just trying to blast the
front side of it so people would see
something else
you know i feel like it's almost like a
camouflage like i got tattoos on my face
so that most people don't want to
approach and talk to me because i have
bad ptsd and i don't know how this
conversation is going to go because i
fear what i don't know without ever
trying it you know so i'm like oh [ __ ]
like if i have these tattoos people
would think i'm scary or like which is
probably not the case or it might be but
you know
it just it was one of those things where
like giving myself this barrier allowed
me to understand
the way i came off to other people and
it allowed me to liberate myself you
know um
my mom told me that she would disown me
as her son if i ever got a face tattoo
so i got bisous on my face
so that i could always have my mom give
me kisses yeah you know even if she
never kissed me again but she still does
in time she's gotten more comfortable
with it um
but
yeah she didn't like 13 year old me with
tattoos that probably wasn't her
her favorite thing
um it's interesting how you and i grew
up because i grew up 10 miles
west of where you grew up yeah like you
know it's wild austin divide
is literally like
right there
so like you could walk over one street
like it's so strange like being in this
side of the city so you're on like let's
say you're on like austin and lake right
there's a little church's chicken right
here and they got a little bodega right
across the street or whatever you want
to call a corner store or whatever
and um bodegas are more like new york
and out here but uh you'd have a little
corner store and everything like that
and literally if you walk one block west
towards like you know
like
kenzie and you know everything like that
you're in the hood like so fast but you
walk in like two blocks into oak park
and you're like oh this is so nice like
that's like what's so strange about
chicago is you have these polarities
these intense polarities like if you go
to the east side of chicago like for a
while i was living on 73rd and kohl's
which is like the far like that's south
shore so that's like the far east side
it's like more towards the hundreds and
then like towards gary um and when i was
living over there like
you know
it was like way different than being
over wet on the west side you know i had
a similarities i'm still in the same
city but it felt like i was in a
completely different place you know
um
and i feel like much more dangerous
yeah and no i think it's all for me like
i understand the eminent danger i think
you pay 1500 to [ __ ]
possibly get shot living in chicago like
that's the price you pay you're like oh
here's 1500 and i might die you know um
and that's always just been something to
register with me just because of
experience like i've seen so many people
die like one of the last articles i read
in the news before i left chicago when i
was like just fed up and tired
was
uh i think like an eight-year-old
eight-month
old baby got shot in traffic on lake
shore drive because of um
an angry driver
they shot into the side of a car over
somebody like cutting them off
like that's insane
like the that you can get that worked up
so fast that you can take a life from
somebody or try to take a life from
somebody and then an innocent life
you know what i mean it's not even the
person who did it almost it's an
innocent life
you know um
but we're more worried about how much
gas costs when we already made electric
cars
and
i see that a lot in society period i see
a lot of people um using their success
to glamorize
instead of change
um if cardi b spent any amount of that
money she spent on the [ __ ] diamond
nipple [ __ ]
things that are metagala dress
it was like all right each one of those
diamonds one of the diamonds not all the
other diamonds that she had on there
just one of the diamonds the major
diamonds that she had that looked like a
nipple okay
literally each one of those diamonds
cost like 30 000
you wore that one night and never wore
it again
who are you helping by doing this
like who who benefited it from but you
and i that's like that's kind of where
my head is as as a 22 year old white man
in america it's like
what did that do for society who did you
help by doing that but we're just doing
a lot of things to look cool we want to
look cool it's way cooler to be high on
drugs because society's telling you to
do it you know
and i think that's a
no one wants to talk about the
the hard things because it's just way
easier to
you know the more i do this project
the more i see the
that the wealth gap is the biggest
problem we have
um
hey i like that in this country
because you'll have people like doing
things like what you just described if
you gave me a million dollars or the
wealthy are just
you know taking it as far as they can
and the poor just get left behind yeah
so you get you get these broken families
that leave children with without good
parents without good role models without
a good education good opportunity all
the money in the world and have a
wonderful family but you could have
no money at all
and have a wonderful family yeah but but
the wealth extreme that yeah but it does
makes it harder it does make it harder
because of the way that we it's kind of
what i was getting at who did you help
buying that dress for yourself yeah
right yourself
you know as where you could have put on
a t-shirt
i donated all the money that i was gonna
spend on a dress to hungry kids over in
you know or like to help relief funds
over in syria and then that's a movement
bro you just made a whole movement and
you look 10 times cooler
or all of us did that yeah you know and
changed the country there's people who
even claim to be politically woke and
politically understanding and have this
understanding
but when they're given opportunities to
show how enlightened and uh
how free and and how
much change they want from the world and
then from america they fish out they
would rather look cool on tv
and that's the big thing is this is very
superficial you know like
no
no one wants to sit down and have a
conversation about their trauma
i will though because somebody's got to
do it
you know what i mean and by doing this i
open up a door for other 22 year old
people to reach out to you or to me and
be like hey i'm struggling with this do
you have any advice could you point me
in the direction to somebody who knows
what i'm going through
and then you create a
foundation in almost a a community that
now
can help each other and that's the thing
with complex ptsd is
most treatment for complex ptsd does not
work
um it's actually can be negative it can
negatively affect the person who's
trying to seek that
most treatment comes from cognitive
behavioral therapy
and the other portion comes from talking
to people who
deal with people who have it or talking
to people who actually have complex ptsd
so it's it's
from finding out that i had this
disorder i had to build a whole
community around finding myself trying
to get better
and it was hard at first because it's it
was hard to well how do i bring this up
in a conversation how do i talk to
somebody about
the million times i've been [ __ ] over
in life you know the time i got stabbed
or the time i got assaulted or the
abusive relationships i grew up in you
know and and as like i said i never
traded for the world
but
in in retrospect it's like
now i have to deal with it and finding
that support system where i was in a
city that's so filled with hate and evil
you know even our even our own mayor
like lori lightful not my mayor anymore
because i don't live there but lori
lightfoot like is a joke like she does
not take her job seriously like she's
trying to fit so much into popular
culture and reach out to a youthful
audience that she's just getting a bunch
of people laughing at her because she
sounds dumb
you know
on a funny note just because you're gay
and and
of a minority group doesn't mean that
you're automatically
the best thing ever
and just that goes for anybody that's
any race any sexuality anybody you know
um but
you got to do what's honest and true to
you to help people and when you're
sitting here trying to
pose like you're a 13 year old kid on
twitter
to help chicago as a whole
you're trying to tap into one audience
when it's the bigger picture you know
i think that it doesn't just
this is something that can be talked
about
for chicago specifically um there needs
to be a major reform in chicago in my
opinion
i think that there needs to be less
prison time and more mental health
i think there needs to be more schools
opening and less less liquor stores
you know i think that we need to
actually [ __ ]
figure out a way to um
what's it called gentrify areas properly
so that we're not pushing minority
groups out
we're actually keeping minority groups
where they're centralized
and
bringing more people of different
ethnicities and cultures into that area
so they can learn more about that
culture and be more understanding and
empathetic and sympathetic you know
instead of running for mayor in chicago
you're out in l.a smoking fentanyl on
the street
yeah
but see that's the thing is
i don't think i'd be happy sitting
behind a desk you know
doing all the other legalities that come
with being a mayor
but uh
i'll say it like this chance the rapper
chancellor apper's dad was a large part
of obama's political campaign
now because he had a son who was in an
industry he probably was able to tap
into an audience that he wouldn't have
been able to tap into if his son wasn't
a musician that was prominent and
successful in chicago plus i've met
chance he's a wonderful person like his
brother
terrible people like i will admit that
to you homophobic even in his own light
of coming out in recent i feel like it's
just all for media it's all what media
wants to hear so he sounds better but
chance was actually a pure person i met
him and i saw like
somebody who wanted to change our city
somebody that loved our city but
wanted things to be better you know
even down to somebody like a mainstream
rapper g herbo who makes drill music
which is predominantly talking about
violence drugs and sex
even he started opening up schools like
montessori schools and different schools
in chicago because he understands
there's a problem and that's like that's
a step in the right direction that's
where we can go with it you know but to
have a bunch of people who are
disassociated from our youthful reality
and what's going on right now
and you know lori lightfoot's just
getting to a point where america is
accepting the fact that she's queer
you feel me so that's probably a big
thing to her you know i'm already living
in a world where it's okay to be queer
and if you want to [ __ ]
act like something's wrong we can box
yeah and that's part of where i come
from it's like it's a very like firm
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna step
down from where i'm standing because
that's there's not enough people
standing up for what's right
i think
the best piece of advice i've ever
received right
was from a drunk man in a bar
but he was so on point though it was
great
he said there's your side right there's
my side and then there's the right side
which side do you choose
and i thought about it for a second i
was like
the right side
obviously
right
and that and that is the right answer
but it took me a second and the fact
that it took me a second is i had my own
selfish desires within
a conversation with somebody where i
didn't even have to be selfish you know
well i'm right uh
well maybe i'm not right
maybe there's a right way to do it
though
um
i think racism
um sexism
uh homophobia
stems from lacks of knowledge the lack
of
knowledge i don't think people are
actually racist i think they're dumb
i think they're really stupid and no one
told them differently or no one showed
it to him in a way but it made sense for
them and it didn't quite comprehend
um i think that
what the problems you see with society
i will say are real they're valid and
they should be
understood and heard
but in my reality as somebody younger
than you
my
group of society has already dealt with
that and we already know that you're
melanin it doesn't matter yeah
that your sexually sexuality doesn't
matter but that's even a bridge like i
got homies who are homophobic and it's
just because they've never
taken the time to understand that
it's just another person homie
you know now
i i will admit that you know like i've
had some experiences while in chicago
um
with like
gay men coming on to me and i definitely
was very uncomfortable and they were
very kind of like almost malicious with
it
um
but at the same time
i never let them get to a point where i
was crossing in my adult life at least
you know like when i was old enough to
fight back when i was old enough to
speak up when i was old enough to make
that difference
i might as well make that difference you
know and not stay silent
because if i stay silent there's one
more person that's living in silence too
you know but if i if i tell the world
the truth and i'm like hey here's my
situation like i could be honest and i
like this my this my truth
i'm a drug addict
with complex ptsd
and i'm just trying to figure out how to
make it work for me
and if i make it work for me i can help
other people make it work for them
and that and that's just literally like
all i want like
how am i going to do it art
music
photography
the things that i know how to do so that
somebody who does
analytics
and somebody who does business
can somehow feel that feeling that i
have and be like
i agree with this change this this
worldly change that he talks about i
agree with this and i'm in a totally
different industry
and that that's real equality in unity
is
real equality in unity says
there is not
four races
there is one race and that is the human
race
we all bleed the same
we all have blue blood on the inside red
blood on the outside
so if you understand that
and for me it's enlightening to think
this way in my opinion like i think this
way and i'm like all right i feel i feel
happy
knowing that i'm not stuck in a racist
mindset trapping myself you know
because
some of the best things in life that
i've that i've come to see aren't of me
and do not come for me
and do not come for people who look like
me
but i appreciated it the same
and that's like
that's
so with cognitive behavioral therapy
it's kind of rewiring your brain to deal
and think about the trauma differently
while doing this and i still do it a lot
and i'm still trying to learn you know
i'm still trying to learn every day if
i'm not learning why am i doing it you
know it was even telling the homie you
know out there i was like you know
what's nice about this is i can go back
and look at a video of myself when i was
22
and be like
wow
so much has changed
in
this time
but yet i was still on to something you
know and then you just build upon it
it's just all about building it like you
know and building the world to be the
way that you want it
because things are gonna happen to you
that you cannot control
and you have to accept the things that
you cannot control
but you have to be able to change them
and know when to change them
and not to change them
and if you really think about that that
leads into one construct of a lot of
addiction which is the serenity prayer
which is the aaa meetings and it's just
building a regimen that is healthier and
happier for your life
you know what i mean
ian
what an amusing talk thank you likewise
it was always fun really [ __ ] nice i
appreciate that we should do this again
in a year or two and see where you're at
i would love to
no i'm serious i would love to that i
would love to come back here and do this
again because like i said next year i
might have a whole new piece you know
you're an interesting young man thank
you like you're you're a cool dude
i appreciate you allowing me
you